[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie
aujourd'hui j'ai la grande joie de
recevoir Marie-Pierre elle est déjà
venue sur notre plateau pour un livre
qui s'appelait qui s'appelle toujours
d'ailleurs
osez s'accomplir elle est auteur
conférencière praticienne des arches
chinois et elle va nous présenter des
nouvelles choses elle a beaucoup
travaillé Marie-Pierre n'est-ce pas
ravi d'être là bah écoutez c'est
partager c'est gentil d'être fidèle à
tv78 et à chaque fois on retrouve aux
œuvres avec beaucoup de joie je disais
tout à l'heure on a beaucoup de travail
aujourd'hui
on va y aller avec le sourire et sans se
compliquer la vie et méthode et calme
bien sûr déjà
qui êtes-vous Marie-Pierre en quelques
mots quel est votre job comment on dit
j'accompagne depuis 25 ans des personnes
sur leur chemin propre d'accord que ce
soit des individuels que ce soit des
couples que ce soit des entreprises
l'objectif est toujours la l'alignement
et le déploiement des forces de ces
personnes
en avec l'objectif toujours de minimiser
les dépenses de force et de maximiser
les talents individuels ou collectifs
donc vous partez du postulat que les
forces elles sont en nous oui
tout ce qu'on en a tous on en a tous et
nous avons la responsabilité au fil
d'une vie de les
identifier de les choyer de les cultiver
et de ne pas nous faire avoir par des
discours ambiants qui nous feraient
croire que nous sommes
des numéros ou que en tout cas la
vitalité individuelle n'est amenée qu'à
s'user systématiquement en fait c'est un
muscle ça se travaille et c'est bon
sujet on va y revenir sur cette notion
numéro dans un nouveau livre vous en
parlez justement alors
prenons les choses par le commencement
vous avez écrit osé s'accomplir dont on
a parlé la dernière fois et pour
compléter ce livre vous avez créé un
coffret voilà un coffre avec des cartes
et puis un petit livret voilà qui est
l'alignement
et des cartes alors l'objectif pardon je
vous termine juste et après vous avez
écrit debout dans la lignée de oser
s'accomplir
voilà et vous avez créé pour
l'accompagner un deuxième coffret qui
s'appelle l'incarnation avec aussi des
cartes voilà donc ça c'est dit donc ça
c'est un concept et j'aimerais bien vous
m'expliquer déjà à l'alignement debout
un petit peu ce que ça veut dire vite
fait et comment utiliser ses coffrets
qui accompagnent vos livres alors donc
il ne faut pas oublier que ma base
quotidienne est l'accompagnement les
consultations le suivi de personnes qui
sont à la recherche d'une clarification
de leur chemin mais aussi au déploiement
de leur force donc
ma pratique propose très
systématiquement des exercices des
outils des des approches des conseils de
posture et est arrivé à un moment donné
où je trouvais dommage de ne pas
partager davantage sans même qu'il y ait
consultation le foisonnement d'outils
simples pratiques
non coûteux gratuit nous permettant à
chacun d'avancer sur ce que j'appelle
notre chemin propre alors chacun de
trouver l'outil qui lui correspond qui
correspond à son alors il y a une
palette il y a une palette et je
conseille parfois d'ailleurs de se
laisser guider par son intuition propre
par exemple quand on a tous les bouquins
vous en prenez un dont la couverture va
peut-être vous attirer plus qu'un autre
ou surtout de pas hésiter à les ouvrir
n'importe où et de voir la pensée le la
phrase qui va en général très souvent
faire écho à un questionnement qui peut
être émergence chez soi mais que nous
n'avons pas encore accompagner
conscientiser donc l'idée de coffret
qui peuvent qui complètent mais qui
peuvent aussi rendre placé la première
approche vers ces ouvrages et ses
conseils c'est de court -circuiter la
pensée linéaire cartésienne et
rationnelle alors je reste parfaitement
cartésienne je pense que vous m'avez lu
vous le savez mais cette capacité de
projeter sur la suite de manière
linéaire
la suite de difficultés parce qu'on a
été en difficulté nous avons une
capacité de
ne pas faire suffisamment de place à la
survenance d'une bonne surprise
par exemple on est dans une dans une on
est dans une dynamique négative alors on
se dit bah ça ça va pas marcher puis ça
va pas marcher absolument et on attire
le négatif peut-être aussi
on n'est pas suffi nous ne sommes pas
suffisamment disponibles pour le rayon
de soleil ou pour la bonne surprise et
la pensée
occidentale est quand même linéaire et
déductive je simplifie à outrance alors
que la pensée chinoise sur laquelle
s'appuie traditionnelle pas actuel ça
puis mon travail est une pensée
énergétique séquentielle thématique le
temps est cyclique
de rater une occasion n'est pas de rater
toutes les occasions donc ce travail ces
outils sont souvent
déculpabilisant et permettre un angle de
lecture que je l'affirme notre culture
occidentale ne nous donne pas d'accord
donc je crée des aiguillages des points
on va dire des rayons de soleil et qui
viennent court-circuiter une capacité à
nous enfermer nous-mêmes sans aucune
critique je me l'applique nous appliquez
nous nous enfermer nous-mêmes dans d'une
démarche qui est en fait non
constructive pénalisante et souvent trop
culpabilise
voilà très bien donc et alors grâce à ça
finalement si on n'a pas la chance de
vous consulter vous nous donnez quand
même pas mal de clés vers l'autonomie
absolue alors l'autonomie alors
l'alignement l'incar debout tout ça
c'est des ça doit être un but en soi
dans la vie ça veut dire quoi être
aligné parce que c'est très à très à la
mode
d'incarnation au début je crois que on
ne le voulait même pas sur la couverture
de d'un ouvrage et ça devient
effectivement à la mode bon en fait
toute la question c'est de travailler
ensuite j'y travaille ça va peut-être
faire peur de de d'envisager la
possibilité de nous rapprocher chaque
jour un petit peu plus de qui nous
sommes vraiment quand vous parliez des
forces pardon c'est un peu les dons que
l'on a l'effort
les qualités innées d'accord et notre
culture quand même valorise souvent la
tête l'intellectuel le raisonnement ce
qui est totalement important mais nous
ne donnons pas suffisamment à mon sens
de place au corps à la posture au
ressenti que le corps nous donne y
compris quand nous nous apprêtons
comment dire
accepter un poste dont nous savons déjà
au fin fond de nous
qu'il va être en non-alignement en
décalage avec lettre que nous sommes
vraiment donc il y a quelque chose on
pourrait dire pas de rebelle mais est-ce
que le papa veut faire peur il y a il y
a une approche qui donne à la voix
propre un petit peu plus de poids
sachant que nous sommes totalement
continuellement bombardé d'informations
de demande de requête de qui nous
mettent en situation souvent
d'impuissance donc ces ouvrages ces
ouvrages
et toute l'approche qui est derrière
nous invite à agir
dans la zone
opérationnelle qui nous concerne c'est à
dire de remettre la question des forces
vives avec lesquelles nous sommes nés au
centre de l'équation et puis
quotidiennement de les aliments d'accord
alors vous parlez justement je crois que
c'est dans ce troisième livre le feu
intérieur ou parler de nourrir son âme
nourrir son âme qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire alors
nourrir son âme on pourra lui dire
autrement plus simplement ou une manière
plus abordable pour tout le monde c'est
de retrouver du sens
au quotidien
dans la majorité c'est pas possible
surtout des actes que nous posons tous
les jours
nous savons nourrir notre efficacité
nous savons nourrir
nos alimentés les responsabilités que
nous avons à assumer mais au bout d'une
journée si nous repassons en les images
de tout ce que nous avons vécu dans une
journée quels ont été les moments ça
peut traiter nu les personnes les lieux
qui ont nourris le sens de la vie pour
nous la question fondamentale du sens
mon propos est d'affirmer que l'absence
de cette nourriture dont nous avons une
responsabilité nous avons à le chercher
ce sens et ça passe par des petits actes
l'absence de cette nourriture dame
fragilise
l'individu
et nous met en situation de perte de
force de perte d'énergie nous détourne
de l'essentiel qui est un travail
quotidien répété d'alignement avec les
forces que nous avons tous moi je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait des lentilles de
la compétence
et puis des paumées de l'existence
d'accord
c'est le regard de la société qui est
souvent discriminant et classifiant et
on peut comprendre pourquoi les sociétés
ont un fonctionné comme ça qui va nous
éloigner d'une lecture
bienveillante de nous-mêmes je dis même
dans le fait intérieur je parle de
chérir nos cicatrices vous dites ça et
vous dites se laisser guider par la joie
aussi ouais ouais et après vous dites
aussi vous dites énormément de choses
très intéressantes lire les signes et
trouver son chemin alors voilà ça c'est
le petit dernier c'est le petit dernier
qui va sortir le 21 mars c'est le début
d'une trilogie voilà les deux autres ça
s'appellera comment alors il y en a qui
est sur en fait de manière surprenante
reculer pour avancer ça c'est très cher
mais quand même c'est de ne pas avancer
et puis l'autre à avoir avec les
conditions du déploiement d'accord alors
on va déjà se concentrer sur les lire
les signes et trouver le chemin alors il
y a un truc en ce moment dans la société
française alors vous vous êtes aux
États-Unis mais vous devez le savoir la
grande mode encore une fois c'est dire
ah bah tiens ça c'est un signal c'est un
signe c'est un signe fin et on voit des
signes partout alors vous voulez encore
qu'on cherche d'autres signes alors
trouver les vrais signes alors en fait
d'abord une pléthore de disponibilité
aussi
le juste retour du pendule après avoir
été quand même pendant deux trois
siècles absolument cartésien et
n'écoutant jamais ni notre int ni les
coïncidences qui en fait sont peuvent
être aussi désynchronicité donc l'excès
à l'heure actuelle il va passer il en
restera quelque chose donc c'est cet
ouvrage
pose pas forcément un cadre parce que ce
serait enfermant mais pose quelques
cailloux sur le chemin comme le Petit
Poucet il est là pour guider dans notre
propre travail de discernement pour
repérer
comprendre et surtout accepter les
signes que l'univers
ne se lasse pas de nous envoyer un signe
peut-être le mal de dos qui serait
installe chaque dimanche soir alors que
nous tentons de nous convaincre que la
voix professionnelle dans laquelle nous
sommes est encore la bonne c'est votre
gros truc ça a les gens qui sont mal
orientés non j'ai beaucoup de personnes
moi je crois que ceux qui m'a en 25 ans
ce qui reste une ligne conductrice de
vos consultations des consultations donc
c'est quand même tous les jours au fur
et à mesure des années reflets de la
société bon et bien mais en fait c'est
le le la texture de souffrance
moi j'affirme évitable c'est génial
nourri qu'on accepte et qu'on devrait
pas accepter que nous moi je
souhaiterais vous avez parlé de la joie
que nous nous que nous nous retrouvions
les conditions d'accès à la joie comme
étant un droit en nous défaisant de plus
en plus de notre capacité d'accepter et
de tolérer la souffrance ou la
demi-teinte ou le la résignation on
accepte trop en fait mais c'est à dire
que tant que nous n'avons pas de
discours ce que font les cartes par
exemple où ce que font les ouvrages les
ouvrez n'importe où là je voudrais
mettre le pied dans la porte tant que je
n'ai que nous n'avons pas sur la table
mais tant que nous n'avons pas de
discours d'abord raisonnable bien sûr
câble parce qu'il s'agit pas maintenant
d'inventer des choses qui n'existeraient
pas et utiles tant que nous n'avons pas
d'autres
axes de lecture
difficultés dans laquelle nous sommes
individuellement mais ensuite après ça
devient presque une situation collective
il est difficile de de comment dire de
s'entendre et puis il est difficile de
dire non le moment venu pas du jour au
lendemain quand même à des situations
qui sont énergivores et qui à terme
parce qu'il y a quand même derrière
aussi tout ça le lien avec la médecine
traditionnelle chinoise le 1 une
résignation une tristesse répétée est
une porte ouverte à des pathologies
physiques parce que nous ne sommes pas
en vitalité parce que
évitable et ce qui est très rassurant
c'est que vous dites que la vitalité
même si on la sent plus vraiment elle
est toujours tapie dans un petit coin ça
vous donner des clés pour aller la faire
ce rallumer sera Vivé et c'est ça la
base en fait ça me touche que vous
l'ayez entendu et perçu
parce que je la compare d'ailleurs à un
animal qui qui reste fidèle mais qui a
qui est abandonné qui nous suit quand
même mais qui dès qu'on va lui faire
signe
et en fait aussi c'est 5 minutes par
jour un certain nombre d'exercices c'est
vraiment facile alors et l'autre jour je
me disais mais quand même pourquoi
est-ce que c'est si difficile de se
faire du bien tous les jours donc moi je
prends le contre-pied en disant mais en
fait non on s'y met donc ne vous
endormez pas le soir sans avoir pu au
moins nommé
un moment alors ça peut être une demi
seconde
joyeux dans votre journée
et je dis même une minute par jour c'est
7 minutes par semaine 7 minutes par
semaine une fois qu'on commence à s'y
mettre il y a le l'émergence d'un cercle
vertueux puis ça peut être 5 minutes par
jour ça fait x 7 etc de la même manière
que lorsque l'on recommence à manger
correctement ou à bouger un petit peu le
corps se le corps réagit très vite nos
forces de vitalité elles accourir
elles sont elles sont juste
en attente non elles sont elles
attendent un signe de notre part donc on
va on va envoyer des signes aussi et
puis on va recevoir on va savoir les
décrypter ça serait génial quand même
voilà merci pour tout ce travail que
vous faites pour nous emmener vers une
belle autonomie pour qu'on retrouve nos
forces et qu'on arrête d'accepter la
tristesse et ce qui nous convient pas et
qu'on arrive à écouter notre intuition
ça le secret retrouver écouter la voix
intérieure qui est toujours là et en
tout cas merci du travail que vous
faites pour je crois donner ses gouttes
de vie à votre à votre public hein vous
merci bon à très vite pour les prochains
petits livres celui-là il est tout petit
on peut maintenant sa poche très vite et
il est mais c'est dense dans le sens où
c'est nucléaire oh je vous fais
confiance merci à bientôt Marie-Pierre
au revoir merci de nous avoir suivi à
très vite pour un nouveau VIP
[Musique]